This is a site we have built with grids
integrated into the login and
operational flows.
I'm going to log in now. I copy the
grid's URL from the site and paste it
here.
Hitting okay. I am then asked to confirm
the messenger signature request or the
message signature request.
I hit okay and you'll see I am now
logged in.
Almost instantaneously I am logged in to
the secure client portal and dashboard.
No password, no credential transmitted.
Now I'm going to show you a transaction.
I generate a payout to be signed.
This could be any transaction type.
I again copy the grid's URL. I paste it
into the grids URL box and I now get a
transaction signature request.
The account, the chain, the network ID,
the originating URL, and the transaction
data. I hit okay. That's already done.
The transaction settled in under 3
seconds. You can see the transaction
hash. This is the proofof work open
resource blockchain Groot that is the
base of the gauaru making the internet
of economics possible. 1,846,200
times more transactionally efficient
than Bitcoin with 8.23 times greater
network security in commercial use. Both
the login and the transaction were
conducted using grids. There was no
direct credential interaction on the
connected layer only the origination of
the instruction to the dead drop
protocol as you saw one more this is
gaju market the world's first onchain
marketplace for goods and services
currently in testn net
you will note that here we see a QR code
this is how gaju mobile will operate you
scan the QR code And by the same
mechanic, log in.
For now, I'm going to use the grid's URL
again. Log in here. Confirm here. Hit
continue here. And I am logged in.
Same mechanism. No password,
no database to breach.
Gaju desk is in use now. Gaju mobile
will deploy in May. These applications
are free to download, install and use.
The solution they offer can be
implemented by any business or
government in the world within weeks,
well within the 90 days cyber security
industry estimates for action. The
protocol is open sourced. The attack
surface that Mythos and any AI of its
capabilities can exploit is now gone if
you choose to make it so.
What you have just seen is grids at
work. This is not future technology. It
is operational now. Maynet launches 26th
April 2026. Thank you for your